｛カコン｝
｛ガサッガサガサガサ･･･｝
｛ガサッ！｝
ある日の話です
私はいつものように郵便受けに
郵便物がないかと思い
玄関まで行ったところ
｛トン｝
｛ガサッ！｝
私には
全く身に覚えのない
とある封筒が入っていました
住所は完全に私宛であり
私に向けられた郵便物であることは
間違いないと思い
その郵便物を
受け取ることにしたのです
ですが
やはり私には身に覚えがなく
この封筒を開けるか、とても迷ったのですが
私は封筒を開けてしまいました
うわあぁ！
怨
～えん～
怨むと書かれた本が入っていました
とても驚きましたが
私は何故か
取り憑かれたように
本を読みまくったのです
からだが勝手に動いてしまいました
ですが、著作権上中身は見せられません
申し訳ないです
本を読むことは止まることを知らず
読み続けましたが
ん？ん、まぁ、まぁ・・・そこそこ
怖かった・・・です
封筒の中には
一枚の紙が入っていました
岡本元・・・これは完全に私の名前・・・
ですが私の苗字が間違っていました
私は知らぬ間に何者かの手によって
逢魔メンバーにされてしまっており
メルマガ会員になっていました
はぁ？
なんだよこれ
なんだよ逢魔メンバーズって
なんだよメルマガ会員って
しらねぇよ・・・
だれだよこんなの勝手にしたやつ！
恐怖
怒り
不安が私を襲い
逢魔メンバーについて
ネットで調べまくった結果
とある事実を知ってしまったのです
よかったぁ
も↑や↓も↑や↓も↑や↓も↑や↓も↑や↓も↑や↓も↑や↓も↑や↓
もぉ↑　も↑や↑も↑やぁ↓しぃ↓
も↓や↓も↓やぁ↑　も↑や↑も↑やぁ↓しぃ↓
も↓や↓も↓やぁ↑　もぉ↓や↓し↓　も↓や↑も↓やぁ↑しぃ↓
も↑や↓も↑や↓も↑や↓も↑やっ↓
もっ！もっ！やっ！しっ！♬